[Music]
foreign
have done to survive Vega was it even
possible firstly let's begin with
talking a bit about the dragons starting
with the smaller one then vegar and
lastly we will talk about how he could
have evaded and survived the gigantic
bees even though he didn't so let's get
to it guys
according to the books at the outbreak
of the dance erax was mature enough to
be written but still young and growing
he was five times smaller than Vega as
described in the dance of the Dragons
his color and exact size was up to
speculation but in the series we can see
that the young dragon erax was a pale
white in color and around the size of a
large horse with a very long tail this
puts him at around 45 to 50 feet long or
13 to 15 meters even though he doesn't
seem to be that big his tail mind you is
super thin and long his head was only
around two feet long but even at that
size erax was a tenacious dragon and had
a fighting Spirit defying Luke's order
and Spitting Fire right on Vega's face
vegar on the other hand is quite the
opposite she is a very old dragon and
was the biggest dragon in the world at
that time close to the size of balerion
at his time of death Vega was pale
greenish yellow in color and has a
length of over 240 to 250 feet long she
is fast for her size and has a wingspan
that would be over 400 feet wide she has
been ridden by several writers before
aemon and was said to be a survivor of
many battles she has quite a temper and
when provoked she would do anything to
kill the other dragons or people as
evident in the episode where she
disobeyed Eamon and killed arags and
luceres so now let's talk a little bit
on that battle and what other things
Luke and Iraq should have done to avoid
the dragon and survive the encounter
so the Rivalry between Eamon and luceris
has been one of the subplots in the
second half of the Season beginning with
Luke severing eamonn's eye the
conclusion comes when they both meet at
Storm's end both vying for the favor of
Boris Baratheon when Luke arrived he saw
the silhouette of the giant dragon
outside the walls of Storm's end like a
scene from Godzilla after an altercation
inside the house they both took flight
on their own dragons and flew away Vega
pursuing the smaller Dragon then losing
track of arax when the dragon flies into
a canyon that is too narrow for her to
pursue against Luke's orders Iraq's
blast Vega with dragonflame enriched
disregarding Eamon as he desperately
tries to reclaim control of her Vegas
Natchez Eric's in her Jaws in the sky
above the storm easily tearing the
younger Dragon apart
so here are five ways that Luke and
Eric's would have done in order to
survive the encounter first they should
have scattered the area firstly and then
turned back once seeing Vega in the
vicinity the giant dragon wouldn't be
that hard to spot even in the rain of
course Luke had a message to deliver but
it could have been done at a later time
knowing that if Vega was there then
Eamonn who hated him would also have
been in the castle but the Young Prince
with no experience ignored logic and
landed anyway not even fleeing when
seeing Vega's silhouette outside the
castle walls the second tactic was to
fly low and in a zigzag pattern when
pursued by the giant dragon of course in
calm weather the smaller and nimbler
dragon would have outflown Vega or
outmaneuvered her as it would be swifter
and more agile but the heavy winds and
rain hindered the ability of the smaller
creature while vegar being way bigger
was not at all affected by the storm due
to her sheer size so the only way to
outmaneuver the bigger she Dragon was to
fly low near the waves as it would have
prevented Eamon and Vega from bouncing
on them from above because in doing so
and possibly missing it would have put
them out of commission and it would be
hard for Vega to take flight again from
the ocean
thirdly was to stay in the Ravine till
the storm ends of course this is easier
said than done but erax actually did
manage to disappear from sight after
going into the ditch staying there out
of sight of flying the opposite
direction would have saved both their
asses then next the fourth a tactic was
not to attack Vega in the storm in the
end we come to know that Eamon wasn't
actually trying to kill Luke but was
only intimidating him or trying to
strike fear and Terror into his nephew
but with erax and rage at the bigger
dragon and spewing hot dragonflame into
Vega's face this led to aim and losing
control of Vega and in the end killing
the other two with a single bite Vega
the bigger dragon would have been the
alpha here and she would not have
tolerated any disrespect to her status
targaryens losing control of their
dragons is quite a common thing in this
universe as we can see from Dany
Daenerys again losing control of drogon
in the beginning as he was still growing
as you know dragons are dragons they
would do whatever they want to the last
technique that should have saved both
their heights was not to climb up and
cruise the skies like a freaking glider
this was the mistake that both of them
did as it allowed Vega to spot them from
inside the storm stalk them and suddenly
emerge from the thick clouds to kill
them both in fact they were both safer
in the clouds as the heavy rains as well
as the thick moisture-laden clouds would
have dampened Vega's vision and they
could have easily lost Eamon and the
Beast in the storm either flying in
another direction or hugging the terrain
or the waves but eh that wasn't meant to
be
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash the
Bell icon for regular updates or new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam